um here's a quick rudy giuliani clip  rudy says um  that  impeaching biden would be logical and  something about being unfit for office  here's rudy rudy looking gaunt by the  way  the grassroots impeachment are one of  the most basic that hamilton lays out  the federalist papers and that is when  he's uh  when he is acting in violation of his  constitutional responsibilities in this  case to protect us and  uh make certain uh  what's really even talking about we have  peace and prosperity he's acting in  violation of his duties to uh save  american citizens  and finally it really i think is a  better case for 25th amendment better  but i would pursue an investigation of  both  i begin an investigation whether there's  grounds for impeachment remember you got  to do that first  and second i begin an investigation of  whether there's grounds to remove them  for  unfit for office all right so there's  rudy's opinion